هل الصدام بين الصين والولايات المتحده
امر حتمي المستقبل في علم الله لكن
العلماء بيحاولوا قرايه المستقبل بالعوده
الى التاريخ وفهم التاريخ وما جرى فيه
والتاريخ بيقول لنا انه على مدار 500 سنه
كان في 16 حاله مشابهه لوضع الصين
والولايات المتحده اي 16 حاله وجدت فيها
الدوله العظمى المهيمنه نفسها في صدام مع
قوه ناشئه تتحداها ومن ال 16 حاله دول 12
حاله انتهت بصراع المسلح واربع حالات فقط
لم تنتهي بصراع المسلح
من امثله 12 حاله التي انتهت بصراع المسلح
اللي هو تحدي المانيا لبريطانيا العظمى في
سنه 1914 ومن الامثله القليله التي لم
تنتهي بصراع المسلح هو الانتقال السلس
للسلطه ولقياده العالم من بريطانيا العظمى
الى الولايات المتحده بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه والكلام ده كله رصده مؤرخ امريكي
مرموق اسمه جرام اليسون في كتاب سماه
مصيده فيو
الكتاب ده اتكلمنا عنه قبل كده وحاطط
لحضرتكم لينك الحلقات السابقه حتى لا نكرر
انفسنا لكن باختصار ايه مصيره هو جرام
الست جرام اليسون هو اللي ابتكر هذا
التعبير في اشاره الى المؤرخ اليوناني
القديم فيو اللي ارخ للحرب بين اثينا
واسبارتا في اليونان القديمه من حوالي
2400 سنه
وثيوسيس كان قد ابدى ملحوظه ذكيه جدا وهو
يؤرق الى هذه الحرب القديمه وخلاصه هذه
الملحوظه انه سبارتا وكانت هي القوه
القائمه لم تكن تشعر بالخطر من اثينا وهي
القوى الناشئه لان اثينا بالضروره تستفزها
ولكن لمجرد ان اثينا تزداد قوه ونفودا
ازدياد القوه والنفوذ لاثينا جعل سبارتا
تشعر بالخطر ومهد ذلك لحرب طويله بين
المدينتين انتهت نظريا
لكن عمليا الحرب اتت على قوه المدينه ومهد
ذلك لاحقا لان الفرس يفوز على او ينتصر
لاحقا على سبارتا بسهوله وبيخلص السن اللي
عدى هذه الدراسه مع عدد من زملائه
وتلاميره الى ان
السبيل الوحيد للولايات المتحده والصين
لكي ينجوى من هذه المصيده ان هم يتعلموا
من دروس الماضي من دروس اللي عملتها يعني
كانت امريكا مشاركه فيها لما انتقلت قياده
العالم من بريطانيا اليها بسلاسه
وهذا لا يتم الا لما يكون القوتين عندهم
قدره كبيره جدا على اظهار المرونه
والتاقلم على حقائق الواقع الجديد
بالمناسبه بيقول انه حقائق الواقع بتقول
ان الصين سوف تتجاوز الولايات المتحده
كقوه عظمى وعلى الولايات المتحده ان تقر
وتدرك ذلك وتستعد له وانه الصين بتتفوق
على الولايات المتحده في كل المجالات بما
فيها المجال العسكري
وبيذكر انه الولايات المتحده لم تستطع منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه والى الان ان تفوز
في اي
يعني نزاع مسلح او حرب دخلتها بشكل واضح
هي دخلت خمسه حروب خمس اربع حروب منها اما
خسرتها او لم تستطع حسمها كوريا فيتنام
افغانستان العراق والحرب الوحيده التي
اعلنت الولايات المتحده الانتصار الحاسم
فيها تالت حرب تحرير الكويت ضد دوله صغيره
وهي العراق
وبالتالي الخلاصه وفقا لوجهه نظر اليسون
وفقا للتاريخ انه اذا ادركت الولايات
المتحده انها ان الواقع يتغير على الارض
وبدات تفسح المجال للصين وبدات تتفاهم مع
وتتعايش مع الواقع الجديد قد ينقل عالم من
مواجهه بين اعظم دولتين في العالم اما اذا
اصرت على قطع الطريق على الصين وارادت
محاصرتها فان الصراع قادم قادم اشكركم
والى لق